[APPLAUSE]
JASON SILVA: Fun.
So Doug, I want to
ask you a little bit
about the themes in "Cyberia."
I'm particularly
fascinated, and I've
been fascinated with this
term "cyberdelics," which
connects the idea of cybernetic
systems and computers
and high technology with
psychedelic substances,
expanding your mind.
There's a lot of
people out there
that think that the
computer revolution is
the literalization of the
psychedelic dream of mind
expansion.
And that the confluence of the
counterculture and the computer
culture in the early
'60s, like, in a sense
sparked this world,
where it was like,
these computers can
extend our minds.
Computers are the new LSD,
and so on and so forth.
You know this world very well.
Do you want to just riff a
little bit on your thoughts
on that?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Well, I don't know.
For me it was kind of
a surprise, you know.
I went to Princeton in the early
'80s when there weren't many,
I don't know, there weren't that
many interesting people there,
to use the word "interesting."
And there certainly
weren't many psychedelic,
counter culturally,
theater people there.
And after I graduated, I
found that the other nine
of the other 12 psychedelic
Princeton people
had all ended up moving
to California to work
in the high-tech industry.
And that seemed really weird
to me because when I grew up,
people who used computers
were the kids who
kind of cut right angles in the
corridors of the high school
and stuff.
So I wanted to
find out why people
who were for the most part
more stoned than I was,
the true deadhead people,
would go out there.
So I went out and spent
time with these people who
were working at
Intel during the day
and going home scraping the buds
off peyote cactuses at night.
And--
JASON SILVA: Wow.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
--trying to figure out
why were these people
attracted to it.
And then why were these people
the ones being hired to do it.
And what I figured
out in the early '90s
was that people who had
hallucinatory experience
were really the only
people who weren't
afraid to build these platforms,
to build this reality.
These were people who were
accustomed to imagining
something that then appeared.
JASON SILVA: Right.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Right.
So these are people who
then had to go and do,
that is their job.
JASON SILVA: Right
off the bat, I mean,
it makes me think of this idea.
You have all these companies
that are talking about
creativity and out-of-the-box
and we got to get our employees
to think differently.
And don't look at what is
but think of what could be.
Steven Johnson and his
book "Where Good Ideas
Come From" talks about
the adjacent possible.
And he says the adjacent
possible is a shadow future.
It's this thing
that's not quite there
and it hovers over the present.
And so how do you
get there, right?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: The
problem here, though,
is that deliberate and
disciplined psychedelics
users bring back what they've
learned back to terra firma.
JASON SILVA: Absolutely.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And implement
it in real life in a real way.
And there's a kind of an
implicit morality in that.
And the kinds of people who
were doing computers then
were the kinds of
people who shared
a kind of a common
sense of values
about people and weirdness and
paradox and the arts and all
that.
And when I look
at the people who
are programming
our reality today,
I see kids graduating
from Stanford,
going to work for Goldman
Sachs to build algorithms
that work on the stock market
to outsmart human traders.
So I don't feel that that value
system's implicit anymore,
that the adjacent possible is
no longer necessarily connected
to the real, but is an
alternative reality.
Let's build this platform.
And it harkens back
to stuff McLuhan
was talking about back
in his dissertation
when he wrote about the trivium.
That there were these
kind of two sects
sort of throughout history.
The grammarians who were very
concerned with sort of what is.
And the dialecticians,
the constructivists,
who were sort of out
there on, what can we do?
What can we construct?
What else can we--
The constructivists,
it was very consonant
with industrialization and
the Renaissance and progress
and where are we going
to go, where are we
going to take this thing?
But you know, that eyes
on the prize mentality
is kind of an abstraction when
it's not counterbalanced by--
JASON SILVA: Being present?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Being present, right.
Being [? by the ?] real.
JASON SILVA: Yeah, and
I understand everything
you're referring to here.
And so it almost sounds
like what you're saying
is that dream that
existed, maybe,
when you wrote "Cyberia."
Or the ideas that
John Markoff explores.
And what the Dormouse says
when he says that this 1960s
moment, this counterculture,
these computers,
this dream that was
conceived and potentially
to be literalized now.
You're saying that the value
system that exists today
is not the same.
So instead of people creating
an app to transform the world,
they want to create
some little app
that they can, like,
put on the stock market
and sell for $1 million.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It became
more the quest, well, yeah.
Or even in the best
case, it's the quest
to make a second life, a second
life rather than this life,
where we are alive.
And we talk a lot
about the singularity.
I get where the
singularity to me
seems to be kind of
a self-loathing, kind
of antihuman, zombie
apocalypse fantasy.
You know, where
the story they tell
is that the history of evolution
is information itself striving
towards greater
states of complexity.
Human beings are really
good, and culture
is really good for doing that
for the last 3,000 years.
But now computers are
even better at doing that.
So people are only going
to be necessary insofar
as we can help
computers manifest
the next stage of evolution.
And to argue, as I do, that
no humans matter is hubris.
Who says humans matter?
And I say humans matter
because I'm on team human.
JASON SILVA: Well,
it's interesting
when Kurzweil talks
about the singularity,
and he addresses
the criticism where
people say, oh,
the AIs are going
to take over and displace us.
He says you keep talking
about the AI as if it's them,
but that's really
going to be us.
I mean, he echoes
some of the ideas
of David Chalmers
and Andy Clark,
who says we need to get
over our skin bag bias.
And that these technologies,
if you zoom out
and you look at it
from the outside,
these technologies are
actually a part of us.
They are our second skin.
Just like the
spider's web is a part
of the spider, our
smartphones, our technology,
our computers are like
a scaffolding of mind.
I mean, when you look at
the Mars Rover on Mars,
that's the human mind
is crawling Mars.
The Hubble Space Telescope
gives us, allows us to mainline
the whole of time
through our optic nerve.
So I don't think that
we're being replaced
as far as being augmented.
But this is my interpretation,
I mean, we are [INAUDIBLE].
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Oh, yeah, it depends.
If you're part of
the camp that wants
to upload human consciousness to
a silicon chip and watch it go,
then you've got no problem
with skin bag bias,
I'll tell you that much.
But I think there's
a danger there
that the problem
with constructivism,
while it's great
to plan, is it's
very hard to remember that
we have to keep testing it
against reality.
What might be has to continually
be tested against what is.
It goes all the way back to the
invention of the first meeting,
the invention of text.
Once we could write things
down, once we could write things
down, we got time travel.
We could write about what
happened in the past.
We got history.
And we got the future.
So then we got the messianism
and Moshiach and all that.
And Moshiach and the future
and where we're going
and tikkun olam.
That's all beautiful as long
as it's constantly tested
against what's happening.
JASON SILVA: Well, don't you
think that language allowed us
to dream?
Because by conceiving of
what might be is sort of--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It did.
JASON SILVA: --the catalyst
for human imagination.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And progress.
JASON SILVA: To
imagine what could be.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And
industralization and all that.
JASON SILVA: To yearn,
to dream, to sort of take
the protoplasmic
yearning of biology
and articulate it
into this beautiful--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It did.
And dreaming is
beautiful as long as,
just like with the
psychedelic trip,
as long as that dream is then
integrated back into reality
rather than engineered as a
way to get out of reality.
JASON SILVA: Well,
OK, definitely.
And one of the
things you talk about
is the comparison between
this digital future
and bringing it back to the
human spectrum of experience.
So I'm really interested
in experience design.
And I'm interested in
technologically mediating
experience, right?
So this is something
I'm obsessed with just
because for my own interest
in, like, being blissed out.
When I watch movies, when I
listen to beautiful music,
when I experience
aesthetic arrest.
These are all
technologies, right?
Cinema, truth, 24
times per second.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Since the beginning.
Since the cave paintings.
And all we've been experimenting
with from the beginning
is kind of challenging
our proprioception,
challenging, where does my body
end and the rest of reality
begin?
I mean, the museums.
If you look at the history
of museums, you see dioramas.
What were they?
Whoa.
And then holograms, whoa!
Then virtual reality, whoa!
JASON SILVA: Faulkner
says, a writer
wants to fit the
world into a sentence.
A filmmaker wants to fit
the world into that film.
You know, when you
go to a museum,
you want to fit history
into an experience that
fits into your now.
It's almost like
you want to process
the world into this moment.
See the world in a grain of
sand and then a wild flower.
So Diana Slattery has that
amazing article about,
she talks about the
term "the trope high."
And she says, whether
it's drug-induced highs
or technological highs, high
resolution, high fidelity,
our desire to just chase these
blissful mind-body states that
seem to be integral to
the human condition.
And us using our tools and
folding those tools back
into the self to essentially
hack perception, hack
experience, hack consciousness.
I mean, don't you think that's
an amazing opportunity for us
to play?
Does that excite you?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It's an
amazing opportunity for us
to play, for sure.
And although I've seen
many acid casualties
along the way of the
people that chased just
a few too many highs, I'd
hate for our civilization
to become an acid casualty.
But the other problem
for me is, who's
building these technologies?
Who are we in concert with?
When I say, OK, so Google's
building these technologies.
And yeah, they're
also building robots
that really are good at chasing
and shooting down people.
And while they're donating it
to the World Wildlife Federation
to chase poachers, who we
all know are really bad,
so that's a very
socially acceptable way
to build robot drones
that chase down people.
And we know Google
will do no evil,
so we don't have to
worry about that.
And the government
will never get a hold.
While we're chasing
our highs, we
are supporting the creation
of a technological structure
that we're not
really in charge of.
JASON SILVA: So
does that scare you?
I mean, do you anticipate, like,
some totalitarian information
state where we're not free?
Or McKenna talking about us
each moving into universes
of our own construction,
where Big Data is used
to create engineered
serendipities
where everything
that's always around
is custom for us and our tastes.
And the smart
systems that start.
We dovetail our
minds to our tools,
but when the tools
start dovetailing back,
the distinction
between self and world
is going to become
really flimsy.
Because everything is
going to have mind in it.
Everything is going
to have my mind in it.
Because everything
is going to be
responding to my tastes and
my desires and my needs.
I mean, I imagine a
sort of playground,
a kind of wake-walking lucid
dream mediated by technology.
Kind of like the end
of "Vanilla Sky," when
he's in that lucid dream.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Could be.
JASON SILVA: That's
what I fantasize about.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It could be.
It could be.
But for me, the
best part of a trip
is always waking
up in the morning.
I mean, coming down
is the good part.
It should be, anyway.
Coming down is the part
where you're, like, OK.
JASON SILVA: What
have I learned?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Now what?
Yeah.
What did I learn and how do I
apply this and what is this?
And then you go out in the
woods and you [SNIFFING]
smell reality again
from that new place.
And you realize, oh,
my god, I've only tip.
I'm only 1% of what I could be.
And I think we've
both shared that.
We're only 1% of
what we could be.
The question is, where
is that other 99%?
Is that other 99% by
building these technologies
that can then do this stuff?
Or are we leaving
that 99% behind
and building technologies
that can house the 1% that we
already know about?
JASON SILVA: You
just said something
that really got me excited.
You talked about what
happens after the trip.
This idea that ego death results
in a kind of reset of the self.
And you go and smell the
roses and smell reality.
And you've been
changed in some way.
You've been conditioned
by the experience.
And you want to go out
and be a better person.
And you want to exercise new
possibilities and so on and so
forth.
So I want to ask you--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And the very
best thing about psychedelics
is you come back and
you see the structures
that you've been
accepting at face value,
as given circumstances
of your reality,
and you see them as
social constructions
of people who may or may
not have had our best
interests at heart.
So when our very
best digital people
are, say, building
Twitter and disrupting
this industry or that.
But then what do they do?
They go to daddy at
Goldman Sachs and do an IPO
and reify the worst
shit of our society.
They basically turn it into
another prop for Wall Street.
The opportunity of
moving into a digital age
is not to build upon the
mistakes of the Industrial Age,
but to challenge
the Industrial Age
and retrieve all of the
values that got repressed
the last time.
That's McKenna's
archaic revival.
That's McLuhan's
retrieval of values.
So what I saw on my
technological trip,
when I saw it was, oh, my gosh.
You mean we can transact
in a peer-to-peer fashion
without corporations.
Oh, we can invent
local currencies.
And we can use our iPhones
to do authentication.
We can look back at
reality again rather than
just build on the
artificial structures
that we've had before.
And my concern is, when we
just go headlong for the high,
there's a ton of
powers that be that
are more than happy to get you--
JASON SILVA: To
serve you that high.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah,
to get you and me high
as long as they get the Big
Data that they need in order
to predict or influence
our upcoming behaviors.
JASON SILVA: So its
revolution or hedonism.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: It's
interesting though,
but sometimes I feel like,
OK, so when I watch a movie,
I'm a consumer who is paying
money, feeding an existing
system, a business that
is a thriving business,
a corporate business that
is, those that criticize film
say that it's like a soma
that's keeping us all placid
and mindlessly entertained.
But when I see a
movie that I love,
I don't necessarily want
to have a revolution
against that system.
I actually enjoy the film,
and I'm glad I live in a world
where these expert
filmmakers can amass
these resources to make these
amazing cultural technologies
for me to experience.
But I don't know if
that just makes me--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: But
we still have those.
And they're still great movies.
Go to a Chris Nolan movie, and
it'll blow your little mind.
I mean, that's a good
thing, not a bad thing.
JASON SILVA: Yeah, but I
guess what I'm saying is--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It's
when we're not conscious.
So then it's like, OK, now I
can make my own movies, right?
And you're one of
the lucky ones.
You can buy a Sony camera
and buy an Apple computer
and buy some Time Warner
Road Runner uplink speed.
And you can now, instead
of paying to watch a movie,
you can pay to make a movie.
And upload it to YouTube,
where Google will own it.
And if you're one
out of 3 million,
you can be one of the few that
becomes luckily you or me.
JASON SILVA: Well, Google will
own it, et cetera, et cetera.
But the point is, technology has
lowered the barriers of entry.
There's been a
flooding of new talent.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: There has
been a flooding of new talent.
But the number of people
that have actually made it
in the DIY system, if you
look at music or filmmaking,
is less than made it
in the old system.
The disparity between
the stars of music.
JASON SILVA: And why
do you think that is?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Why?
Because I think it's actually
because they're not really
selling the music.
Because what we're
really selling in
this system are networks.
And I was just talking to Oliver
Luckett, who runs theAudience,
whom you know.
It's a social media agency
for rock stars and pop stars.
And what they realized is, if
you're going to be a pop star,
you're not going to make
money selling your records.
What you can make money doing is
selling your Twitter followers,
is selling your Facebook likes.
So what they do is
help you amass--
JASON SILVA: It's a currency
of attention, right?
Attention's the new
limited resource.
There's an infinite amount
of signals competing
for our attention.
We're all suffering
from bandwidth anxiety.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Right.
You could take
Adderall for that.
JASON SILVA: But those
with the loudest microphone
or amplifier in the
age of information,
that's where the
wealth is, right?
You can control attention,
you can control the world.
It's interesting
because in the book
"The Mating Mind," the
guy talks about how
the human capacity for
creativity, you know,
language, art, poetry, is
really just the human version
of the peacock feather.
And that we went from trading
in genes to trading in memes.
So today, evolutionary
success is really
those that are controlling
the Twitter followers.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Right.
I mean, and people
like me were the ones--
JASON SILVA: They're mating
their memes the widest
and farthest.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Honestly.
And it was little
schlemiels like me
who liked the trading
with memes thing
better than the trading
with genes thing.
That's why I couldn't
live in Los Angeles.
I had to come to
New York where I
can get currency with the things
I say rather than my flesh.
JASON SILVA: Rather
than your six pack.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
And you got both.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON SILVA: So
I want to go back
to what you were saying before
about resetting the self,
coming down from the trip,
whatever that trip was,
technologically mediated
or drug mediated.
And the therapeutic aspects
of these experiences.
Because one of the
things that I've
been obsessing with lately,
and I've done videos about it,
is the subject of awe.
And I tell people
that awe is, to me,
it's a sort of an antidote
to existential despair.
You know that I'm really
into Ernest Becker.
He says the human condition
is defined by the fact
that we know that we
are mortal beings.
So we lose sleep over the fact
that one day in the future
we're going to die.
And that imbues the
human experience
with a kind of absurdity, right?
We are simultaneously
gods and worms.
We can ponder the infinite,
yet we watch those
that we love get old, ourselves
get old, and eventually die.
And so I find that whether
it's psychedelic therapy
or whatever, inspiration,
awe, aesthetic arrest
are the antidotes
to that experience.
So ego death, being
blissed out arrests time,
temporarily pushes aside
thoughts of impending doom,
takes us off that people
mover that's carrying
everyone else towards death.
And then there was a study
that came out of Stanford where
they basically exposed
people to experiences of awe,
which they defined
as experiences
of such perceptual
expansion that people
had to upgrade their
mental schemata
to accommodate the experience.
And what they found
is that people
who have regular
incidences of awe
are left with increased
altruism, increased well-being,
increased feelings of
compassion towards other people,
et cetera, et cetera.
Like there's all these takeaways
after blowing your own mind.
The therapeutic aspect.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: There are.
And awe was
systematically extracted
from the human experience
over the last 600 years.
Because people in awe, people
who have awe experiences,
are dangerous.
We're unpredictable.
JASON SILVA: They
get hit by a car
because they can't
cross the street.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Which is why
we have psychedelic medicine.
But psychedelic drugs,
they're still drugs.
They're for people who are sick.
They're for a society
that's lost the ability
to encounter awe.
And they reacquaint
us with awe, not so
that we have to do it
again and again and again.
As Alan Watts said, once you get
the message, hang up the phone.
But rather to be able
to experience awe,
as I am right now
just sitting with you,
or looking at my
daughter, or having sex,
or looking at a sunset.
It's like awe, awe, awe.
The awe is everywhere.
Do I need that medicine?
Now the technology is also
good because you can't
get everybody high on acid.
We found that in the '60s.
People are afraid.
But the computer, great.
All right, so let's give
people some awe experiences.
Great.
Not so that they can then
travel into the computer
into the land of awe.
But so that now
that they recognize
awe, or a simulation
of awe in this case,
they can come back to the real
world and go, oh, my gosh.
JASON SILVA: But it's true.
But the existentialist
philosophers
were always saying it.
I mean, Camus used
to say, life should
be lived to the point of tears.
I mean, you read
the romantic poets.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Life should
be lived to the point of tears.
We should go to a movie
to experience a simulation
of someone else's life.
You can go into virtual--
JASON SILVA: Because we can't
have it in our own lives.
Perhaps that is a tragedy.
But you know what
the problem is--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: We can
have it in our own lives.
It's a thing.
It's here.
It's available.
We don't need to pay
Google for the awe.
This is a way for white,
Western, patriarchal--
JASON SILVA: I still want
to have my iTunes playlist
with the custom
music that I picked
to be playing conditioning
my real experience.
So I still want to
use the technology.
I still want to
borrow from the--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: But also
there's a reality out there
you can listen to, too.
JASON SILVA: Like just
the trees rustling?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
The trees rustling.
I mean, gosh, my
favorite thing when
I lived in the West Village,
back when that was affordable,
was there was a
public school there.
And I would stand at the chain
link fence when they had recess
and listen in perfect stereo
to all the kids playing
in this thing.
And that was awe.
But it was awe.
It was right there.
JASON SILVA: I've
always envied people
that just are naturally in awe.
My mother's one of those people.
She's just one of those people
who says everything moves her.
She finds beauty
almost in everything.
And then some of us that have to
find ways to mediate and induce
an occasion that experience.
So it's just something
I'm really interested in.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Now
your stuff, your videos
are medicine in that sense.
Because people are, you're
at work, you're doing this,
you hear about your stocks,
and does it go up or down,
and private school, my kid.
And now I can watch
a three-minute video
and go whoa, fuck!
[LAUGHTER]
And that's the point, right?
That's the point.
JASON SILVA: Well,
I mean, the 100%.
The videos, I try to
explain to people.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Brain games.
I mean, what do you do?
You're teaching people
to play with their brain.
Play with your brain,
it's here for that.
JASON SILVA: Yeah,
it's interesting.
Because the reason I
did those videos was,
thank you for using
the term medicine
because I did them
as self-medication.
It was like if I was in any kind
of stupor, if I was afflicted
by the banality of the every
day, the been theres and done
thats of the adult mind,
as Michael Pollan writes,
I needed to be reset.
And not every month
does Christopher Nolan
release a film.
So you've got to wait for them.
So when there's
nothing I can purchase
to give me that
experience, I want
to go and make that experience.
And finally I have
the tools, right?
And so I have limited resources.
And perhaps kind of
a limited attention
span, and kind of impatience and
a desire to just make it now.
So rather than spending six
months doing a feature doc,
I was like, I want to make
these three-minute videos.
Because I want to take
a three-minute hit.
Like a hit of DMT.
It's just like a three minute.
But I want it to have all the
energy of the most amazing
movie trailer you've ever seen.
And all the ideas
packed in there densely.
And I want it to be
like an inception.
You watch it, and then
it goes and percolates,
and it stays with you,
and this and that.
Yeah, I mean, for me
it's been medicine.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
No, and it's cool.
The trick, though, is to help
people understand that you're
not necessarily
describing reality,
but you're giving metaphorical
ways of understanding reality.
So the mind is like a processor.
You know, we are like computers.
We are uploading stuff.
Memes are like genes.
And we are infecting
one another with ideas.
JASON SILVA: I love
those metaphors.
They help me understand
the world a lot more.
It makes everything make sense.
That's the thing about
those kinds of metaphors.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: No, it does.
They're just prone.
In our society
those metaphors are
prone to the sort
of Margaret Mead,
Gregory Bateson abstracted
understanding of reality
as this kind of participatory
mediated spectacle.
JASON SILVA: I love that term.
OK, so let's talk about
cultural operating systems
and the consensus trance.
You were talking
about that before,
that when people have these
psychedelic experiences,
they come out of
it and they realize
that these social,
rigid frameworks that
seemed so solid and
so real are much more
fluid than we think they are.
They've been created
by other people.
What do you think--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
It's the same thing
that happens when you watch a
Shakespeare play, or a Brecht
play, or have good sex, or go
to a good religious ritual, too.
JASON SILVA: So
what do you think,
how can we upgrade our
social operating systems?
Do you ever speculate of
what a better society?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah, I
mean for me, it's funny.
JASON SILVA: Do we
all run around naked?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: For
me, the digital thing
is so key because we have
migrated from an industrial age
society to a digital one.
But for me, the
digital is the opposite
of the kind of global,
Google, meta network thing.
For me, digital was
always the digits.
It was about return.
These are the digits.
That's what digital means.
A return to the fingers.
Not to individuality as
individual consumers,
but to local means
of production.
And for me, though, the whole
local thing, the Etsy thing,
the retrieval of
medieval values,
and Burning Man, and Occupy
are all about the same thing.
I mean, I love Occupy,
not in the terms
of the political occupation but
the idea of occupying reality.
Let's Occupy.
JASON SILVA: Own this space.
Be here now.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Digital does that,
because I was a kid who went
from the television mass media
experience to the digital
experience, which was
so peer-to-peer and connected.
JASON SILVA: It's
interesting to hear you talk
about occupy this, be here now.
I haven't been to Burning
Man, I'm embarrassed to say.
But I need to make
it over there.
I read Eric Davis's
essay on Burning Man.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And
you've been there.
JASON SILVA: Oh, my god.
But one of the things--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And
now it's not Burning Man,
it's not Burning Man
anymore than the internet's
the internet.
I mean, Burning Man
is where, you know,
if you're a young Google
executive, you go and prove
you're cool by
living in a trailer.
JASON SILVA: But the people
that have transcendent
experiences there,
to me it seems
like the place creates this
kind of radical novelty
that by virtue of
just being bombarded
by the juxtaposition
of so much originality,
it's so different than
what you see every day.
You don't have mental references
for what you're seeing,
so it induces that wonder,
that imagination explosion.
And what that does is
it's like a drug, right?
Serves the purpose of
transforming your perception
of the present moment
and the passing of time,
the unfolding of time, and
just experience changes.
Subjectivity is transformed
That's interesting
because the hacking of
subjectivity is like--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
But to the purpose of then being
able to recognize and foster
the things that you
see in real life.
I was at a tree-trimming party
with a pinata the other day.
And the pinata fell,
and all the boys
are shoving and
kicking and trying
and everybody gets their
candy and their little toys
and all that.
And we're all like, oh, my god.
This is all so--
And then 10 minutes
later, nobody's
looking because then
the kids are off.
I see, like, five
girls in a circle,
and my daughter's one of them.
These are eight-year-old
girls in a circle.
And they're trading
candy with each other.
And it's this very
sophisticated sort
of modalities of what
different things are worth.
There's a piece of plastic, it's
like a toy, and that's worth--
And so immediately
a peer-to-peer
bazaar in the medieval sense.
A bazaar assembled.
It was social, it
was commercial.
And I was, like, it happens.
It does happen.
That was Burning Man.
It happened there
without the drugs
and without the computers.
JASON SILVA: Right, right.
So OK, I want to ask
you about creativity.
Just like big word.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I should
ask you as the creative one.
JASON SILVA: Well, we're
both creative guys.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
I'm the author.
JASON SILVA: How do
you just randomly just
define creativity?
Moments of aha.
What happens when
human beings step out
of their usual
mental frameworks?
What happens?
What happens in the
brain, what results?
How do you define creativity?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
For me, creativity
is, almost a fun way to
describe what creativity
is, and no one has a great
definition for it, especially
in a market society.
But creativity is when humans
do what only humans can do.
Creativity is the
expression of the paradox,
you know, the ambiguity, the
queerness, the weirdness.
It's these unique,
novel possibilities.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
Well, it's interesting
because I've
been thinking a lot
about what you just said,
that ambiguity
and this and that.
The word "liminality" has
to do with the in-between.
So I've become really
interested in these immersive,
site-specific interactive
theater experiences.
I was talking to you about
"Punchdrunk," "Sleep No More."
There's another one in Brooklyn
called "Then She Fell,"
which is a reference to Alice
tumbling down the rabbit hole.
And in these theater
experiences they
create this space where you
can pretty much go anywhere
you want.
And it's this nonlinear,
interactive experience
of the narrative.
So you don't
experience it in order,
and you kind of are connecting
the dots as you experience it.
And figuring out
what's going on is
kind of the purpose of
what you're supposed to do.
But I describe the
experience as being
inside of someone else's dream.
And so it is this liminal space
between dreams and reality,
kind of like when you're
watching a movie, kind
of like when you're
watching a piece of theater.
Time, space, they
kind of collapse.
You can criss-cross and
cross-cut to anywhere,
experiencing anything,
and you believe it.
So that's the landscape
of mind and the landscape
of imagination.
Do you think we'll ever be
able to create virtual reality
technologies that allow us to
essentially live in that space
all the time?
To live in landscapes of mind?
To just completely leave
behind the sort of gravity
of the body and its
rigid, have to feed it,
have to go to
sleep at this time?
Just live in this
wonderland all the time?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: My sense
is if we do it, it will be,
that the price will be we
leave behind a few billion
of our fellows to be in
nonmediated, wonderful, virtual
things.
I mean, it's the great way
to get the city on the cloud,
so we can all be
in virtual reality
as long as we have little
brown people in subcontinents
feeding the coal into the
whatever, into the processors.
JASON SILVA: That's assuming we
wouldn't have, like, nanotech
or solar technologies
that could make
this perfectly sustainable.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah, it is.
It is.
Because I don't think that
we would have the drive
to inhabit an alternative
reality unless there
was something we were
trying to get away from.
Be it some Philip K. Dick in
apocalyptic, dry desert future.
It's like, oh, shit, I'm
going into Second Life.
See you later, honey.
JASON SILVA: So you always
think that the appeal
is that this is bad and
that is good, rather
than this is pretty good.
Humanity's come to
this certain point.
But now there's
this mental universe
we can go to that's
infinite and boundless.
That was the dream
of cyberspace.
There were corridors
of the mind.
William Gibson.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I think the
better the virtual realities
we build, the
better I would think
people will get
at distinguishing
between the virtual
and the real.
JASON SILVA: Kevin
Kelly says real
is going to be a really
relative term in the future.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Yeah, but Kevin Kelly
is a person who as a
certain kind of Christian
imagines the end of the world.
I mean, there are
people that are still
stuck in what I
would consider to be
a Renaissance-era linear arc
of sort of beginnings, middles,
and ends.
They're not playing
the infinite game
where the object of the game
is to keep the game going.
They're still playing
a Renaissance-era game,
where the object of the
game is to win the game.
They're stuck in the
culture of the book.
And I write books.
I love them.
But books are about
beginnings, middles, and ends.
Whereas games, video games, are
about keeping the game going.
JASON SILVA: When are
you going to write
a book that never ends?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Can't.
Can't do it.
Luckily.
But no, I mean, it's--
JASON SILVA: When
Kevin Kelly talks
about the technium, when
he describes technology
as the seventh kingdom of life.
And he says that
it's a living thing
subject to evolutionary forces,
that has wants and needs.
Do you think that
this is just crap?
Or do you think that there's
a truth to what he's saying?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I think
it is like a living thing.
I think it's
algorithmic in nature.
It's a program.
And while people are very
algorithmic at times.
JASON SILVA: Is
biology a program, too?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
It's like a program.
And there's many things that
are programmatic about it.
But the more you hone
in on that program,
it squirts away from you like a
tomato seed under your finger.
And you realize, oh,
it's not the DNA,
it's the proteins
around the DNA.
Well, of course.
Well, now we know.
Oh, it's the proteins.
Oh, it's not the proteins.
It's like something else.
JASON SILVA: Well, a lot of
complexity for sure, yes.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It's not
just complexity, though.
It's not.
I'm not, in the end,
I'm not a materialist.
I think that there's something
going on here that we don't yet
know about.
I guess it's Kantian or
something, that we barely
even perceive reality, much
less are we able-- We can't even
recreate a simulation
of what we perceive,
much less the 99.9% of reality
that we don't perceive.
JASON SILVA: So are you
talking about the limitations
in understanding our
own consciousness, not
to mention our limitations
in creating instruments
to perceive the world?
Because we can't
see the very small,
but we create a microscope.
We can't see the very large,
but we create a telescope.
We can peer into the, like,
the universe pretty vividly.
You're saying what?
You're saying--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: These
guys buy a model vague,
buy a model of reality,
and it may be true
where there was this
matter, there was a boom,
and then all these things
banged into each other.
And they got more complex.
And they got so complex
and eventually there
was emerging
consciousness from it.
That there was the Big Bang,
and then there was time.
Well, what if they're wrong?
Because they still
don't think that at all.
JASON SILVA: So
you think there's
a more satisfying answer?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: What if
consciousness preceded the Big
Bang?
What of consciousness
was a prerequisite
for the Big Bang rather than
the result of the Big Bang?
Then if it was, then,
well, wait a minute, now
what are we playing with?
So if we don't understand the
sort of very basic building
blocks of reality, I'm
concerned about ditching reality
for another one.
I love Playland, I love
Disneyland, I love movies,
I love all these things.
But I would never
mistake them for reality.
Disneyland is a great idea.
I mean, a world where the
trains worked on time,
I feel like Disneyland
is what would
have happened if the Nazis
had won and weren't evil.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON SILVA: Oh, god.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
And that's fine.
That's fine.
But it's not the world.
JASON SILVA: But let
me ask you something.
You talked about how,
OK, you like movies,
you like video games,
but they're not reality.
One of the interesting ideas in
Chris Nolan's film "Inception"
is this notion that the dream
is real when you're in it.
So if the simulation,
if the representation,
can become immersive enough,
can you ever essentially trick,
hack, or convince
your brain to forget
to remember that it's subjecting
itself to a simulation?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yes.
Absolutely.
JASON SILVA: For
example, when I went
to see "Gravity" on IMAX
in 3D, which I thought
was a technical achievement film
I'd never seen before in terms
of the places where
the camera could go,
it just didn't make sense.
You couldn't place it.
And it was so immersive that
during certain sequences,
my body would jolt with
the movements on screen
as if it was happening to me.
It was going primordial,
deeper than my ability
to remember this is a movie.
And I think that
eventually, more and more
of our simulated experiences
are going to be like that.
So it won't matter
if they're not real.
When they're done, because
when you're in them,
they will become real.
The dream will be real
while you're in it.
What do you think of that?
[LAUGHTER]
It's a cool idea, right?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
JASON SILVA: I'm just trying
to convince you to like this.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I like it.
I just don't like it
more than what I got.
I like it, sure, it's
great, it's great,
cool, go for it, wonderful.
But if we are going to build
these things, let's go back
and say, OK, what's the
purpose of these things?
The purpose could be just
because I want to get high.
Just like the kid taking
acid in the AC/DC parking lot
instead of in the dorm room,
trying to figure out the world.
So you're going to do it, and
you're just going to get high.
JASON SILVA: The
purpose is catharsis.
Well, we would talk about
psychedelic therapies.
But it feels like
human beings, we
need to have regular
experiences that are cathartic.
These ego death,
rebirth simulations.
I was talking about Alan
Harrington, who wrote
the book "The Immortalists."
That even our lovers,
even when we're in love,
our lovers act as stand-ins
for various dream figures
in a stage-managed resurrection.
Where the pilgrim without
faith can die and live again.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: So why
not just do it in a dream?
JASON SILVA: We need
these archetype spaces,
these landscapes of mind,
where we sort shit out.
Like that's the world, the world
of the self, the world inside.
And that's what these
movies connect to, I think.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: They do.
They do, and that's fine.
It's just the world of
the self can be ultimately
a lonely place.
It's not a social place.
Work on yourself.
Sure, you know.
And this is New York.
Everyone goes to therapy for 45
minutes once a week or twice.
I mean, they all know what
that inner work is about
and why it's great.
But the reason we do inner work
is that we go out of the office
and then engage
with people and deal
with the real problems
of distributing
the surplus of stuff that
we have in America somehow
to all the people that need
it, instead of burning food
every week and ripping
down houses in California
because the prices
aren't high enough.
It's like the practical
concerns are so real.
JASON SILVA: I completely
agree with you.
But the practical concerns are
also, they are being addressed.
I mean, there was an article
in "The New York Times"
recently that said that the
lowest level of poverty,
the most extreme
form of poverty,
has almost been eliminated
across the world.
You have Steven Pinker,
who wrote "The Better
Angels of Our Nature"
and his TED talk,
"The Myth of
Violence," that says
that, contrary to what
you see on the news,
the chances of a man dying
at the hands of another man
are the lowest than they've
ever been in history.
I mean, there's all
these indicators
that things are getting better.
But the media feeds
us doom and gloom.
So I mean, obviously, everything
you're saying is true.
But it's not like there's not
an active effort right now
at addressing the fundamental
challenges of humanity.
Do you have optimism
at all in that space?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Oh,
I got lots of optimism.
I just want to
make sure we don't
use these medicines the
same way that, say, America
uses Prozac, which is a way--
JASON SILVA: Fair enough.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: --to--
JASON SILVA: To numb.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: --to
numb, yeah, exactly.
To help us cope
with reality as it
is rather than engage reality
to make it less painful.
JASON SILVA: And on
that note, I think
it's time for our
Q&A. It's about 9:00.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And
don't assume that this
is like pro-anti here.
We're both pro and
anti and all that.
It's sort of the rules
of brain jazz, in a way.
You kind of stake out positions.
On another night, under
different medications,
we could as easily be
taking opposite stands.
It's just sort of
where I'm at right now.
Really it all for me, it's
my disappointment in Bitcoin.
JASON SILVA: I read an
article about that today.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It really is.
I'm disappointed.
We have the opportunity to
invent entirely new currencies
rather than just
remake an investor's
speculative central currency
in a digital format.
It's, like, so stupid.
INTERVIEWER 1: Mic check.
Hi.
You guys talked at
different points
throughout the brain jam
about these value shifts.
I think you talked about
how in the Industrial Age,
we got stripped of some
pre-existing values,
and we got some new ones.
And I've heard other people
refer to the digital age as
also a knowledge age.
Some of the values are
already kind of like embedded
in what you're saying.
So like the
peer-to-peer network.
That's obviously kind of
like a value that rises up,
post-Industrial Age,
whatever we're in now.
Looking into, like,
let's say 2050,
where you do have this kind
of radical transformation,
radical kind of integration
of organic matter
and artificial solar
technology, all this stuff
just like it's at
a mature stage.
I wouldn't say it's
stabilized, but it's definitely
like at a mature stage.
What are the values
that humanity will hold
and prioritize in the future?
JASON SILVA: Who knows?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
You're going to be here.
I mean, I think
right now that's part
of why this moment's
so interesting is
it's up for grabs.
You know?
Right now we are
choosing whether we're
going to reify the values
of the Industrial Age, which
are efficiency over time,
extracting value out of people
and resources, and all that.
In order to push
through somehow,
do the Industrial
Age on steroids.
Or are we going to
use this opportunity
to do some cultural resetting
and retrieve the values that
were repressed the
last time out, which is
when the Renaissance happened?
When the Renaissance
happened, we
got the invention of the
individual, and centralization,
and perspective.
We got a whole lot of values.
And other ones were
oppressed, like women, women,
and peer-to-peer,
local, the bazaar,
all those kinds of things.
I would love to say
in 2050 we end up
in a reality where
80%, 85% of our needs
are met locally through
peer-to-peer networks of people
we're engaged with in
the places that we live.
And 10% or 15% of
our weird, cool stuff
comes from big international
high-tech companies that
make us phones that have
very big supply chains, that
will move into either
some kind of a world with
and many cottage industries
that are all networked
and it would be
vastly more efficient.
Or if the Big Data
people have their way,
we'll end up entirely
more predictable
than we've been before.
And we'll be easily
influenced to just purchase
whatever the next thing is.
JASON SILVA: There
was a recent article
that said that physicists
discovered basically
a law of physics that can
predict the growth of cities.
So even the behavior
of human beings
and the unpredictable
changes that
happen, that it can all be
described by an equation.
That cities are like
organisms and they have
all these metabolic rights.
So who knows?
Maybe what Big Data
is going to reveal
is something that it
scares us to admit,
which is that we're not
really these free, autonomous,
creative beings.
Even though it feels
that way subjectively.
But at a macro scale and
looking at all the data
points, that we're just
algorithmic cascades after all.
And we have to maybe
live with that duality.
Like sure, the Big
Data AIs can predict
everything we're going to want.
But it doesn't feel
that way to me.
For us it'll feel like
we live in this carnival
land of novelty, where
everything is interesting
and everything is awesome.
And people in the
imagination business in 2050
have storytelling
technologies that
are dazzling in their
capacity to wow us.
And the movies like "Gravity" in
2050 will be that much cooler.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And the
materialists, you know,
dismiss this sensibility.
They call it essentialism.
Oh, it's essentialism.
You're a sophist.
You know, it's some
weird, romantic,
melancholy for this idea
that human beings are weird
and that your perception matters
so that you have free will.
This illusion is
good enough for me.
I'm going to work with it.
I'm going to act
as if, I'm going
to behave as if this is real.
And as if they are the ones
who haven't figured things out.
And at the very
least, there's to be
a balance between
materialism and whatever
we want to call this.
Spirituality, for
lack of a better word.
Rather than having
to fall all the way
into one camp or another.
And throughout history they've
generally moved hand in hand.
And it was really only
after the invention
of sort of rational science
and that this stuff that we're
talking about got pooh-poohed as
being some kind of whoo, weird,
womanly Fritjof Capra,
Wu Li Master nonsense.
Where I think it's real.
It's as real as your
perception of reality.
And your perception of reality
is more, I would argue.
All we really have to go
on more than the metaphors
we have to describe it.
INTERVIEWER 2: Thank you.
Hey, guys.
JASON SILVA: Hey.
INTERVIEWER 2: Quick question.
JASON SILVA: Where are you?
INTERVIEWER 2: Here.
So do you think drugs and
psychedelics are still
going to be around in
the age of singularity
or 50 or 100 years from now?
Like, how are people
going to get high?
Is it going to be in the form
of a hack or computer code,
or how are they going to open
up those doors of perception?
JASON SILVA: Well,
this is the thing.
Even the way that people
describe drugs, in most cases,
is not as interesting
to me as some people.
I don't know if you
talked about this.
But this guy, Rich Doyle,
whom I really enjoy as well.
He says that drugs are actually
information technologies.
And the philosopher Eliade calls
them technologies of ecstasy.
And he talks about
humanity's cognitive toolkit
as essentially stuff
that we found in nature,
but we've been using it as
part of our mental toolkit
for tens of thousands of years.
So I imagine we're going to have
a new generation of smart drugs
because, just because
it's chemistry doesn't
mean it's not technology.
These are still
going to be tools
that we use to play with
the essence of self.
And I think that the
best is yet to come.
People read a book
like "Brave New World"
and they're like, oh, the soma.
I don't know.
I mean, there's a guy
called David Pearce.
He wrote "The Hedonistic
Imperative" on the internet.
It's a wonderful treatise about
how we're going to use nanotech
and biotech to create dazzling
new spectrums of subjectivity,
like realms of mind
that are unfathomable.
As unfathomable to us as
the nuances of Shakespeare
are to a great ape.
And so it's useless to
even speculate, in a way.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
And if we get really,
really good at fine tuning
our shamanic alchemy, and we
can play the brain exactly
as we want it, you know, cool.
But there's something that the
mushrooms tell you that that
synthetic perfectly
modulated chemical won't.
The mushrooms are
going to tell you
some stuff you may not
want to really hear
when you're high, like you're
fucking up the planet here.
Hey, you're cheating on
your girlfriend there.
Why haven't you talked to
me in the last three years?
I have something to
tell-- I mean, it's like--
JASON SILVA: It's not
a guilt-free high.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: It's
not, it's not guilt.
I mean it's not, it has, the
plants, the sacred plants,
have agendas.
We are in relationship
with ayahuasca,
we're in relationship
with the Torah.
And the ones that we make
we're not in relationship with.
Then we're just going.
So again, I think it's
a bit about balance.
Rupert Sheldrake
talked about there's
a morphic genetic field
of our whole species'
memory with the plant.
Maybe, but I think
it's the plant.
I think it is the
plants that we've
been in relationship with
for however many millennia.
Understand, and they can
help balance us in ways
that we might not choose
to balance ourselves
if we moved exclusively toward
designer chemicals and designer
states of consciousness.
INTERVIEWER 3: Hey, guys.
I just want to say thank you
for just blowing our mind,
and that was way too fast.
But bear with me while
I work this question.
So first and
foremost, in a society
where the only socially
condition and accepted plane
of consciousness is kind
of that producer/consumer
plane of consciousness, where
the only way that we can afford
ourselves the opportunity
to explore the world of art
and spirit is exactly to do
so, is to afford to do that.
And create a company
where maybe we
can unfurl through our
creative mind in that company.
But of course, a
company or a business
is there to create financial
security, to create money.
I just want to know, how can
we afford the opportunity
to stay in this world, the
world of art and spirit
and mind the soul?
But what I'm really
interested in
is, what was your
answer to this question
before you were Douglas
Rushkoff, media theorist
and author?
Or Jason Silva,
futurist techno-optimist
and philosopher?
How did you live
into this answer,
and how has that changed now
that you're on the other side?
Because you made it.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I
mean, I was lucky.
For the first eight or
10 years of my career,
I made $8,000 to $10,000 a year.
And I just didn't mind because I
was having fun while the yuppie
scum were all going to work.
You know?
So that was the beauty of
coming out as a slacker.
Because it was celebrated
that with me and my friends,
the idea was not
to have to work.
That's why now when I look at
Obama talking about job, let's
create jobs for everybody, it's,
like, who wants a fucking job?
[LAUGHTER]
I don't want a job.
I want stuff and
access and all that.
And I'd like to create things
and have meaningful engagement.
But I don't want a job.
A job is an artifact
of the Renaissance.
People didn't have
jobs until 1300.
They used to make
stuff and trade.
They only got jobs when it was
illegal to make stuff yourself.
You had to go work for
a chartered corporation.
So when I hear questions
like that, it's, like oh,
because we're accepting the
premise of this BS Industrial
Age business model
that was there
for kings and bourgeoisie,
who have long since left
the building.
And we don't even remember
it's their operating system
that we're keeping going.
So there's that.
Lentils and rice is another--
JASON SILVA: I love
lentils and rice.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah,
but you can live--
JASON SILVA: I still
eat lentils and rice.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: You
can live a long time
on lentils, rice, and water.
You can.
And fine spices and stuff,
without even being freegan,
you can survive.
And I did that for
a good long time.
And I tutored kids
on their SATs.
I mean, that taught me a lot
because I was in Beverly Hills.
I would drive to these Beverly
Hills mansions in my used Ford
Escort.
And I'd park between the
gardener and the maid
and then go tutor
some super-rich kid
for three hours for $35
an hour or something,
which is enough to live a
week if you did it frugally.
So no, it was--
Maybe those were easier
times than now on some level.
But I was lucky, and
frankly, the fact
that I was shoved out the chute
of an Ivy League education
after Westchester High
School childhood, I mean,
you've got such an
advantage already.
You're not being put
out on the ground.
At that level of wealth, of
an upper middle class parent,
you're being shot out.
You've got a long way
to go down before.
So I'm a child of
privilege, you know.
I see it that way.
My fellows at Princeton, who
are all these private school
rich kids, saw me as the
poor kid is the funny thing.
You know?
It was luck.
And not getting off the bus.
I think the big
thing is, I've never
worked for some other thing.
So everything I did was
investing in my own,
I hate to use the word, like,
brand, but in my own franchise.
In me.
So it builds.
The freelance lifestyle is more
secure than having a real job.
Because they can't fire you.
When you lose this contract,
you've got five more.
JASON SILVA: Well, it's funny
you say that because there's
some school of thought that
says that in the future,
everything is going to
be essentially freelance.
And people talk about the
rise of the creative class
and these people
empowered by technologies.
It was some article I read
that was unbelievable.
It was saying that there's a
sort of mentality of people
living in places like
Berlin or Williamsburg,
Brooklyn, that think
it abominable to have
to work for somebody else.
And these are like
these creative people
that have the education
of the upper class
but maybe the income of,
like, the lower middle class.
And so they're like these super
intellectually affluent people
that don't necessarily
need things.
So they're not as
dependent on money
because they don't need
to buy as much stuff
because they have everything.
Just their laptop and
their iPhone, that's it.
So that's really interesting.
But to answer your question.
I mean, I think for me, Steven
Johnson has a great line.
He says, the world
is full of clues
and you can read
your way through it.
So I've always kind of
felt that, like, the signs
are there, connecting the
dots on how I can do my thing
and make it work.
I was lucky enough to
grow up in a household
where my parents, like,
encouraged me to kind of find
my bliss, just make it happen.
But also I think there's
little techniques.
George Carlin, actually,
was interviewed recently
about his career.
And he was talking about
psycho cybernetics.
And he discovered this
book on psycho cybernetics.
Are you familiar with this?
And he was saying that
the brain is essentially
a goal-seeking mechanism.
And that there's these
devices, these tricks
you can use to
create impressions
in your brain that then
teach your brain what
to look for in the world
to connect the dots
to achieve your goals.
So he says the first impression
is, OK, you get an idea
or you notice something
that inspires you.
And you're like, oh,
that's what I want to do.
Or that's what moves me.
So that's impression one.
Impression two is
you write it down.
So you write it down.
You're already making
a second impression.
You're acknowledging it,
you're writing it down.
Impression three is looking
at your notes later.
And then by that point you've
kind of primed your brain
with this trajectory of this
network of ideas or concepts
or whatever things
are turning you on.
And then what happens
is a few days later
you're walking down the
street, and all of a sudden you
start noticing all these
serendipitous signs that
are connected to what
you were thinking about.
And people always call
that magical thinking.
They're like, oh, it's the
secret, I'm attracting it.
It's not that.
It's that you've
primed your brain
to connect the dots using
that meta pattern, right?
Because the signs
are always there.
You can read
anything in any way.
But in a way you're
kind of like hacking
your brain to pay
attention to the clues that
are going to help you achieve
what you want to achieve.
I feel like I didn't know
about psycho cybernetics.
But it actually echoes a
lot of the things I've done.
Like, if I look at
my notes from, like,
three or four years ago, I
have little, these scribblings
and these lists, describing
exactly what ended up
happening in my life.
Like exactly like
where I was going to be
and what I was going to
do and describing it.
It's just crazy how then you end
up having those patterns just
marked in your head.
And then you kind
of, it's a thought.
INTERVIEWER 4: Is it on?
Wow.
What a question.
So I've been reading a
lot of history recently.
And it seems to me that
in the large scale,
all of human history's
kind of like humanity
trying to get up on its knees
and reach up for this higher
ideal, and falling again,
and then reaching up again,
and then falling again.
And Kierkegaard said
that the good is slow,
the evolution of good is slow.
Because when you
have revolution,
it destabilizes
what's already there.
And that just causes
more revolution,
whereas when the good
is slow, it's evolution.
It doesn't leave anybody behind.
And that was just a comment,
that wasn't a question.
But I recently read
in a Russian magazine
an article that questioned
several spiritual leaders,
Christian, Buddhist,
just [INAUDIBLE] people,
some professors, about their
psychedelic experiences
and what that had to do
with their spiritual growth.
And they all
unanimously said that it
had nothing to do with
their spiritual growth.
It did cognitively, and it did
with their experiential growth,
but nothing to do
with spiritual growth.
And in my personal opinion, I
believe that the whole point
is spiritual growth.
Well, their amazing psychedelic
experiences, they said,
really corresponded
to their state of mind
and what they were primed
to find in the first place.
So wouldn't the intention,
whether of a good trip
or building up this amazing
alternative reality, world
first, wouldn't the intention
be a lot more important
than the actual trip
or the experience?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I mean, for
me psychedelics seem much closer
to psychotherapy
than spirituality.
And part of that
is because there's
a duality implicit in
taking a drug, right?
There's before
you take the drug,
and while you're on
the drug, and after.
You're getting high.
So high means, and
then you're low?
So there's this sort
of duality in it.
And for me, I got
really into this idea
of birthing another
human species
through collective whatever.
It was sort of when I was back
in the rave psychedelic mode.
And I thought that the
ultimate spiritual progression
of our species would be
to achieve meta organism
and then give birth
to some other thing.
And then so I had that.
Then I get married and
have a kid and went,
oh, that was easy.
Well, hard, but you
know what I mean.
But that was like, it's like,
the real tools of evolution
have been staring me in
the face all the time.
And they are more subtle.
They are more slow.
They're not these giant,
system-wide, revolutionary
leaps.
Revolutions are what?
Revolutions are circles.
That's what they do.
I'm into Renaissance,
which is what?
Rebirth.
Rebirth of old ideas
in a new context.
So you get a new technology, a
new media environment, and now
we can retrieve
things and bring all
those who didn't come along
with us and go, oh, my gosh,
those aboriginal
people that we thought
were all doing nonsense.
They actually have
the technology
that we need in order to
get incrementally forward.
JASON SILVA: I concur.
[LAUGHTER]
INTERVIEWER 5: Hi.
JASON SILVA: Hi.
INTERVIEWER 5: So
Douglas Rushkoff
touched on this
before on the fact
that the agendas
matter, like the agendas
that we have matter.
And so I guess what I'm trying
to ask is that, to Jason Silva.
When you talk about this future
where our technologies advance
so much, and
singularity, and what's
going to happen
after that, don't you
ever feel afraid that things
will advance so quickly
without necessarily thinking
about what we want to do,
what our agendas are
when we have this future?
I feel like, what happens
if these things do end up
in the wrong hands?
Or if it's in the right hands,
but we don't necessarily
know what to do because things
are moving too fast for us?
JASON SILVA: Sure.
I mean, there's a great article
in the website for The Edge
Foundation that was saying
that when the astronauts first
turned around and took a
picture of the Earth from space,
that changed the story
of who and what we were.
That picture provided
a different context
and a different way of seeing
and understanding ourselves
and in turn changed the story.
Changed the context,
changed the story,
changed reality of what we are.
And that now in the
face of these emerging
technologies, that we
are due for a new story.
And I'm not a scientist.
I tell people, I was hearing
this filmmaker once saying,
I'm in the feelings
business, or I'm
in the imagination business.
But I feel like my
small contribution
to that is the exploration
in the media that I make.
So my short videos
are speculative,
and they're about technology.
But they're also
about metaphysics,
and they're about
the human condition,
and they're about love,
and they're about loss.
And they're meant to provoke a
conversation and a discussion,
you know?
And I always say, I just
want a seat at the table.
You know what I'm saying?
Because I agree with you.
I think that we need to be
talking about these agendas.
And I want to be part of
that conversation, for sure.
That is an ambition
of mine, for sure.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: That's funny.
I remember the first few
times I was interviewed
when I did my first book.
What are you doing?
I just want a seat at the table.
I used to say that all the time.
I just want to be a part of
that conversation, a real part
of that conversation.
But the thing is, then you
get your seat at the table.
And now, which is sort of where
she's going, it's like, well,
now what?
Now you've got your
seat at the table,
and then you realize,
oh, I'm not a journalist.
I'm a propagandist.
Right?
And that's OK.
So what am I?
What am I?
Because we're all propagandists.
There's no such thing
as balanced journalism.
That was such a stupid
idea, that we'd be balanced.
It's like, where do
you put the fulcrum?
JASON SILVA: Stop
pretending, exactly.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
So instead we're
arguing for something.
We're fighting for something.
We're trying to persuade
people of something.
We're trying to at least get
our mirror neurons activated
by people agreeing with us.
But then what do we
want to throw out there,
is where you go with it.
And it's funny.
For me it started, I used to
say, oh, what I'm trying to do
is get people off
their bad trip.
I felt like I'd go in
front of audiences,
and everybody's, oh, technology
and this and, oh, the internet.
I'm going to change.
I'm going to have
to learn something.
JASON SILVA: You
told me that that's
the phase I'm in right now.
I'm getting people
off their bad trip.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Get
people off the bad trip.
JASON SILVA: That's my phase.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: To say no, no.
It's going to be OK.
Waking up is not
going to be so hard.
It's going to be OK.
Everything is OK.
Don't worry, don't
worry, don't worry.
It's all right, have fun.
And follow them
down their corridor
so that they really believe
that you understand the terror.
So that you can take
them out of there.
But then it's
like, so then what?
Then what?
I mean, and you can do that
because the phase of life
that you're in, you
still have the exuberance
to make people feel comforted,
you know, and OK and excited.
But then it's like, OK, so
then when they're on the trip,
now where?
JASON SILVA: Who's
steering the Starship?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah,
what do we do with that?
And I tell you--
JASON SILVA: It's
a work in progress.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Yeah, but the ones
who have been steering the
Starship, I don't trust them.
I mean, whether it's Mark
Zuckerberg or Sergey Brin.
They're at that side.
Or whether it's Ray Kurzweil
or Kevin Kelly and those guys.
I don't trust them either.
I feel like they are
still in the story.
You know what I mean?
They're still trying
to figure out a story.
And what story are
we going to tell.
And I think it's time,
stories are for children.
You tell children stories at
night so they go to sleep.
And you try to dose it with some
programming about the morals
that you want them to
have when they grow up.
But I think we're
past stories now.
We're in something more like
a game, or more an adventure,
or more an experiential
something like the theater
experiments you
were talking about.
It's a different way
of taking people.
INTERVIEWER 6: Hey, guys.
This side.
And kind of related to that.
In this age where
technology and social media
are kind of like this limitless
extension of our individual
being, can it be kind
of counterproductive
in interpersonal communications
where, especially young people,
there is no delete key?
And it's kind of taken them
away from improvisational
face-to-face conversation,
where they're
uncomfortable
interacting with people
where they can't go back and
delete what they've said.
Where now there's this kind
of insecurity in just talking
face to face.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: And
then throw the market
on top of that
and a value system
where you actually have a
number of how many friends
you have as a way of judging.
You have metrics for your
popularity and success.
It's tricky.
94% of human communication
happens nonverbally.
So what happens when you grow
up in an environment where
you're using text to engage?
You end up with a kind of an
induced Asperger syndrome,
where you don't
make eye contact,
you're afraid to
you don't know how
to establish rapport.
You don't know how
to not just stand up
in front of a group of
people, but to engage live
with one other person.
You resort to this.
Or you relate through the selfie
rather than through the self.
JASON SILVA: I agree with what
you're saying to an extent.
But I also think that
that is a criticism that
is biased in favor of
the communication style
that we're comfortable with
and that we're used to.
And this assumption that
this new one is not as good,
et cetera, et cetera.
But Kurzweil, who is a
friend of mine, he says,
look, we're not going to be
interacting with each other
through these
square-shaped devices.
I mean, these are
temporary growing pains.
These devices are going
to be shrinking down
to the size of blood cells.
They're going to
be in our brains.
Sending a text message is going
to be very different than going
down into a screen like that.
We'll be able to just send
our thoughts to one another.
Maybe we'll transcend
verbal communication.
Maybe we'll transcend words.
We'll be able to
become each other
and merge our consciousnesses.
I mean, there are all these
speculative, exotic things
on the horizon, potentially.
But I think to criticize
it now as if it
was the end of the way humans
communicate, I'm like, no.
It is what it is.
And if you are not
a fan of it, then
make sure you practice
being present.
But I wouldn't label it,
like, the end of the world.
It just is what it is.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I don't think
it's the end of the world.
But I think it has to
be balanced, is all,
by some real-world engagement.
I get concerned when I see kids
in a classroom with a teacher,
and they're all looking
at their tablets.
You know, it's like,
no, when you're
in the classroom with a
teacher, you shouldn't even
be looking at the book.
I mean, remember
"Captain, My Captain?"
They put away the
poetry book, and they
engaged with each other.
Our face-to-face
time is so minimal.
And how are we going to
know what the nanos should
do if we aren't experiencing the
full breadth of what we already
have?
JASON SILVA: I
think we have time
for one or two more questions.
And then we have some vodka
for you guys if you're over 21.
Thank you to Russian
Standard Vodka for providing
the free vodka bar after this.
INTERVIEWER 7: OK,
so you guys obviously
have a lot of views on
psychedelics and stuff.
But what do you think
the most legitimate
and, I guess, the most efficient
way to reintroduce psychedelics
as a legitimate tool?
JASON SILVA: It's
already happening.
I mean, the majority
of Americans
now in the latest polls support
full marijuana legalization.
The majority of Americans.
So that's not even
taboo anymore.
And as that becomes more
mainstream and more legalized,
you're going to start to see the
emergence of a class of citizen
that is not the stereotypical
stoner with the bong hit
playing video games.
But what's going to happen
when these, oh, my god,
all these screenwriters
like to get high?
All these brilliant
thinkers like to get high?
Wow.
Oh, not everybody uses it in
a destructive, addicting way.
Oh, so this is a tool
for your creativity?
Oh, that's interesting.
A recent study that looked at
semantic priming in marijuana
found that marijuana
actually induces
a state of hyperpriming,
which means it
expands your associative net.
It expands your
capacity to connect
the dots between seemingly
disparate ideas, a sign
of creativity right there.
Or at Johns Hopkins
University, where
they're doing psilocybin
mushroom studies with people
who have terminal
illnesses and making
them process their own mortality
in a radically different way.
I think even the government.
I mean, there is going to be
a psychedelic renaissance.
And I think we're already
seeing it a little bit, right?
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm certainly more
interested in that
than watching Big
Pharma neutralize
the inside elements
of these drugs
and turn them into coping
neurotransmitter modulators.
Which is where they went
with it in 30 years.
And luckily, I mean, the
plants are still there.
They're still, well, it's
not illegal yet, I guess.
A lot of seeds are illegal.
So the whole thing
with seeds and Monsanto
and copyrighting
your genes and stuff.
That gets really tricky, too.
Because if we take that,
it's like right now it
feels to me like
the technosphere
and the marketplace
are equivalent.
And if we can somehow
parse them from each other,
I'm going to like the
technosphere a lot more.
Because then the agenda,
then it's going to be like,
what's technology for?
To make us more human.
It's to realize our
full potential, rather
than what's technology for?
Well, it's to enhance the--
JASON SILVA: What we can sell.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Yeah.
What we can sell.
Or how we can extract data.
JASON SILVA: Fair enough.
OK, one more question.
INTERVIEWER 8: OK, that's me.
I'm the lucky lady right here.
Thank you so much for
this conversation.
Incredibly invigorating.
Jason, you are like an
electrifying optimist.
And Douglas, you're a very
reassuring practical person
for me.
"Shots of Awe" is like a
lightning bolt of inspiration.
And I got super high on it.
And then I was like, crash.
Wait, there are some things
he's just not talking about,
and Douglas brings them
into the conversation.
So what would be incredibly
awesome for me in my world
is like a super organism the
way that a flock of swallows
flies through the sky.
Like if humanity could
take that metaphor
and, like you say,
use technology
to become more human and more
telepathic and more in touch
with each other, that we're
like aesthetically, peacefully
in harmony through the sky.
That's what I want.
Now what I see as
the barrier there
is the digital
divide and education.
For me, education is that,
like, exponential wormhole
that could take us to this
utopic future that you talk of.
And I would love to hear
what your thoughts are
from a systemic perspective on
how we can improve and enhance
the system of education.
Because I've worked in
education for a long time.
And I'll tell you the
statistics, the facts.
In New York City,
40% of our kids
are not graduating
in four years.
That's more than
500,000 students right
now, snapshot,
that are not going
to graduate in four years.
That's the size of
the city of Atlanta.
So it's like a whole city
subsidy within our city
that are not going
to be literate, let
alone digital literacy, which is
all these amazing things you're
talking about, which
I'm so excited about.
But I'm at a loss.
And so I'd love to hear the
conversation and debate,
like, what's going
to get us there?
Because I believe we're
going to get there.
But I just need a little
bit more to hold onto.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
Well, I mean, just briefly,
I agree with the problems
that you're talking about.
But I think education is
due for a massive upgrade.
I think the whole idea of how
we teach, and how we learn,
and whether it's
doing more fMRI scans,
and introducing
crazy psychotropics
into the classroom.
Maybe after you're 18.
No, but I'm just saying,
like, I think we need to--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: You
just lost the job as--
JASON SILVA: --completely--
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: --chancellor
of the schools in New York.
JASON SILVA: I
just think that we
need to not have an educational
system that is still of, like,
the Industrial Revolution Age.
I mean, I went to a
Montessori school,
which has a kind of different
philosophical agenda.
But at the same time, I
think these technologies
and these tools are giving
us radical new opportunities.
I think there was a Bill Clinton
article in "Time" magazine
called "The Case
for Optimism," where
he says, forget about the
haves and the have-nots
because the cell phone
was one of the greatest
inventions in history to
pull people out of poverty,
for example.
And the idea of
the digital divide
is actually not
what we thought it
was going to be because
people are wired,
people are going
on the internet.
Whether or not they're using
that to watch LOL cat videos
or actually learn stuff
online, that's something else.
I'm a big fan of
Sir Ken Robinson
and a lot of his
ideas about education.
And kind of like, not try to
turn everybody into a robot
and so on and so forth.
But my mom also taught for
five years at the South Bronx.
So I'm also privy
to a broken system
and understand how
that works as well.
But I just think, throw
away what's not working.
Be willing to upgrade
the whole thing.
Put everything into
question if we have to.
Start from the ground up.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: I
mean, yeah, it's funny.
This question brings up
everything sort of I've
been thinking about tonight.
I mean, on the one
hand, the thing
I did after my decade of awe
was look and basically said,
I'm going to go to the darkest
places of mind and of reality
and test my awe.
And I'm going to go as deep
as I can, without losing it,
and then pull back and figure
out how to work with it.
So the first thing, I
went to South Africa
before the elections and go
around Soweto and see basically
test myself in the
darkest possible places
to then look, what do we do?
As a way of challenging
my awe and earning
my awe by going dark.
So when I go dark,
I'm not a pessimist.
But rather than just talking
people down off their bad trips
now from my happy young place,
what I do is I go into the,
the only good trip
is a bad trip.
I go into the bad trip so that
I can then find my way back.
I get as lost as I can in
the despair of, oh, my god,
and money and blah, blah,
blah, and then come back.
Education is definitely
one of those places.
And education is the place
where we can say, OK,
we can use digital technology to
build on our education system.
And make kids more job ready.
And teach them code, and do
this, and give them that,
and so they can get into IBM.
In other words, and that would
be the constructivist approach,
the dialectic approach.
We're going to build
on top of that.
Or we can say,
digital technology
and the big digital changes and
opportunity to go back and say,
and this is what the
sophist would do.
This is what the grammarian
would do in this situation, is
go, what's education for?
What is it for?
Right now what it's for, if you
look at Ellwood Cubberley, who
created the modern American,
New York education system.
It was to create, we all know,
workers for American factories.
So that's why they have
bells after every class.
This is why your
school is like that.
They're trying to make
you a good factory person.
The teacher is the foreman.
And you students
are the workers.
And the bell rings.
You go to the next place.
You learn, you memorize this.
You do that.
Follow my orders and go.
Do you have a hall pass?
No, good.
That's what it's for.
It was constructed to do that.
And now, we're like, well,
what is education for?
And it depends.
It depends on what we think
the future of the economy is.
I mean, if education
is to create
a new peer-to-peer
society of creative people
who are engaging, if we
accept the fact that we only
need people working
10% of the time
in order to give everyone enough
food and shelter and stuff they
need, what are we doing with
the other 90% of human activity?
So then what you have to
do is go back and you say,
oh, education is to imbue
people with the ability
to do critical thinking.
The need for the
liberal arts education
is actually more important
now than it was before,
because now we need
a generation who's
going to ask the big questions.
If anything, the
purpose of education
now is to create the people who
can develop the next education
system.
JASON SILVA: There you go.
It's very meta.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF: Go
meta on it, but, yeah.
JASON SILVA: Cool.
Well, thank you, guys.
Join us for a drink.
DOUGLAS RUSHKOFF:
Thank you, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]